welcome back now it's the SNP spring
conference in Edinburgh this weekend and
the First Minister Nicola Sturgeon will
say later that it's time for Scotland to
become independent
well the SNP is leader in Westminster in
Blackford has taken a break from his
speech prep to talk to us this morning
thank you very much for being on the
program today so we're we're expecting
to hear from Nicola Sturgeon later and
talking about the reasons that she
thinks there needs to be another
Scottish independence referendum are you
worried that some people will think that
you should be focusing on some of the
really crucial and critical issues in
Scotland domestically rather than
pushing for independence at this time
well you know but the SNP has been a
government that Edinburgh since 2007 to
12 years and if you look at what's
happening you look at many of the polls
have come out over the course of the
last few days and the popularity of the
SNP or and indeed of the attractions for
independence I think you can see that
there is a wide demonstration of public
support for what the SNP is doing and I
think there's a very sharp contrast with
the chaos they can see at Westminster of
a government that's not working for
anybody and certainly not working for
the benefit and the people of Scotland
and here we have an SNP government that
is getting on with a dear job you were
talking earlier about climate change but
of course we've got world and leading
climate change targets here in Scotland
we're prepared to go further but I think
can all these key issues what we've done
is we've shown leadership and I have to
say this Sophia but no 20 years on from
devolution 20 years the Scotland has
changed dramatically and I think our
message to the people of Scotland is you
like what we've delivered on education
and on Hill the fact that we don't have
to issue fees in Scotland was another
clear example the time now is to
complete that journey and to make sure
that we can protect the economic
interest of the people of Scotland by
being an independent country in the
European Union a summer making Scotland
the destination and so at making sure
we've got the powers to grow the economy
make sure we've got the power so we can
invest in health and education that we
can eradicate poverty in Scotland we can
deliver a fairer society so there's a
very sharp contrast with the agenda that
the Scottish National Party has and our
aspirations for Scotland and what we see
is a UK that's becoming increasingly
inward looking then
much focused on Brett's that tumbling
its back on free movement to people we
don't want to have anything to do with
that
hey you're saying though that people
like what the S&P you doing things such
as education but actually there's been a
lot of criticism hasn't about the
education at the minutes in Scotland I
mean if you look at the 2015 piece a
report for example I mean that's the
most latest one even though in this
couple of years ago its cautious schools
recording their worst ever performance
scores for maths reading in science all
declining I mean it's not as if it's a
really rosy picture and education is it
know I have a lot of change in education
but I think the harsh reality is and
john swinney
who is our education secretary give an
outstanding speech yesterday about how
were closing the attainment gap at
people from poorer backgrounds are
finding increasing chances of going on
to university university places for
scottish students has increased
dramatically over the course of the last
ten year period there is i mean we're
very serious about closing that
attainment gap that is working and what
would continue that progress over the
course of the the next few years i think
we've actually got a very proud record
when it comes to education of attainment
I mean nickel surgeon said she wanted to
make education her number one priority
in yet you know very recently we've seen
stories from reform Scotland for example
saying there's been a reduction in the
number of courses that Scottish
schoolchildren can study Holly Roos
Education Committee hearing evidence
that in some schools 14 year olds and
eighteen year olds have been taught in
the same class I mean you're talking a
lot about universities but when it comes
to schools surely there are things that
you should be focusing on now to try and
improve what many families and children
are experiencing well of course we've
had the introduction of the National
Curriculum hidden scope and something
that was supported on a cross-party
basis and what we're seeking to do is to
make sure that we're preparing young
people for life after school and as a
very key element of that is that is
increased debt that we're seeing in the
subjects that Scottish schoolchildren
are learning so of course I think it's
more important to make sure that the
quality and the value of that education
improved that's very much what is
happening the Scottish government wants
to make sure that there's enough depth
and breadth in the curriculum which has
been offered to young people are making
very clear that that is our priority
okay and now we know of course that any
class station talking later about the
reasons for another independence
referendum you mentioned a little bit
earlier in the interview some of the
polling which has shown slight increase
for support for another referendum but
at the same time it's not exactly a
decisive surge I mean the YouGov Thomas
poll for example as support for Scotland
leaving up to 49 percent it's still not
over that 50 percent barrier is it well
the fact is we've spent the last three
years trying to see if we can get a
compromise and brexit we've talked about
the nobody-nobody 90 such thing as a
good wreck so we think that all of the
United Kingdom should stay in the
European Union but at the very least we
should have stayed in the single market
and the customs union because that would
have given the best protection for jobs
so that's been our focus so over the
course of the last years we've not been
talking about independence what we
signaled this week is that we're making
that determination that independence is
the best option for the people of
Scotland and we're going to be going out
on the doorsteps over the coming weeks
and months and we'll be presenting that
case the vision that we have of a
prosperous independent Scotland a
socially just Scotland and that starting
position is one where support for
independence is virtually neck-and-neck
with the status quo and about the Femi
say-so Sophia there is a poll out this
morning in the Sunday Times that shows
very clearly in the light of in New Deal
scenario then support for independence
would increase quite dramatically but
I'm looking forward along with
colleagues they're having that debate
about what is the future for Scotland
and we want to encourage other parties
to engage in that debate with us as well
we believe that independence is the best
option but let's build a political
consensus let's make sure that we can
actually have that debate about how we
can deliver sustainable economic growth
in Scotland how do we improve the life
chances of the people of Scotland and
I'd simply say to the people of Scotland
is that since we've had devolution 20
years ago Scotland's change has changed
for the better we need to make sure that
we are that destination in Europe that
we do have access to free movement of
people that's so critical if were to
draw the Scottish economy if we don't
have that then we won't have that
ability to deliver sustainable economic
growth to the extent that we want and
there's a sharp contrast of the
emigration policies which are being
pursued by the Conservative government's
that openness that desire to make sure
that people can come and live and work
and be part to Scotland story and indeed
that opportunity that we should have as
a right to live and work and 28 EU
Member States as well so there's a very
sharp divide in terms of what we see is
that positive message that we're
delivering and the contrasting that with
aut which is turning inwards on itself I
actually quite firmly believe that when
we have that debate with the people of
Scotland support for independence will
rise markedly we will complete that
journey to independence Scotland
Scotland will become an independent
country that's implicit of Westminster
that you have to respect that when the
SNP won the election to the Scottish
Parliament in 2016 it was with a
manifesto commitment there there was a
material change in circumstances that we
had to have that right to have that
referendum the people of Scotland
dissolved and that should be able to
determine their own future and
Westminster should listen to that the
way they to stop and no deal breaks it
from happening is to effectively sign up
to some kind of deal and what's been
pretty clear from the votes that have
been held in the House of Commons is
this the thing that seems to be the most
likely path to building a majority is a
customs union I mean last time it failed
by just 8 vote so why didn't you SNP
back that but what the SNP did back was
a motion that supported single market
and customs union because let's remember
that services of 80 percent of our
economy and a customs union does not
protect the service economy and the one
thing that I've continually mentioned is
that importance of free movement of
people we can't grow the economy unless
we have that so it's really important
that we retain that alignment with the
single market that has to be the
absolute minimum and I certainly believe
that if we do have an indicative votes
process and Parliament over the coming
weeks that we can win that argument
across party for a single market customs
union option that is a spirit of
compromise of the SNP has sought to
engage in over the course of the last
few years
customs unions on it so and wouldn't do
it and also there's an additional factor
is because we all have to be aware of
the responsibilities that we have to
support the Good Friday Agreement in the
island of Ireland and a customs union
that engine in itself wouldn't solve the
border issues that are so important and
so entangled to the Good Friday
Agreement
so just to be clear there are no
circumstances so the SNP would back the
customs union I did that has been put
forward well what about you gives that
the Customs Union on its own doesn't
satisfy the needs of herd economy it
doesn't protect the service sector in
Scotland and it doesn't protect that
free movement to people which is so
important we need free movement of
people were pretty able to have the
labor that we require for our health
services for our true this industry and
so on and so forth it simply doesn't go
far enough and at the end of the day the
responsibility that we have is to
protect the economic interest of the
people of Scotland that is why you need
to have that partnership as an absolute
minimum of membership of the single
market and the customs union is the only
way that we can do that that is the
least worst option a brexit there is no
such thing as a good bridge that directs
it is going to cost jobs and our
responsibility is to make sure that we
stop that damage we stop that chaos we
stop the loss of income the loss of jobs
that people in Scotland Olivia right
throat United Kingdom will suffer from
if we do and have that option okay now
just finally and you've said that you're
not going to be attending a state dinner
for Donald Trump in June I mean he's the
US president why won't you have dinner
with him well I think it's very
important that we should you respect the
people of the America and the people and
of course of the office of the
presidency itself but of course when we
look at what President Trump has been
doing the way that he's behaved that we
he's behaved in a misogynistic manner
the way that he's trampled over the
rights of minorities the racist way in
which is behaved it simply wouldn't be
the right thing to leo the red carpet
and to sit down on the basis of a state
dinner and have a pleasant evening with
the president of the night estates of
course the United Kingdom should be
engaging with the US we should be saying
to President Trump that the way he's
behaving he's talking about building the
wall in excluding people from Mexico as
an example is simply not acceptable and
we've had a long debate this morning on
your program about climate change the
fact that President Trump is a climate
change denier that is refusing to sign
up to the Paris Accord
we simply
support what the US president is doing
it would not be the right thing to do to
be sitting down and having dinner listen
okay in black food I will let you get
back to conference thank you for taking
the time to be on the program this
morning thank you